اطلق ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان مشروع الاستثمار والتخصيص الاديه
الرياضيه وذلك بعد اكتمال الاجراءات
التنفيذيه للمرحله الاولى تحقيق لمستهدفات
رؤيه السعوديه 2030 في القطاع الرياضي هو
يتضمن المشروع مسارين رئيسيين الاول
الموافقه على استثمار الشركات الكبرى وجهه
تطوير تنمويه في انديه رياضيه مقابل نقل
ملكيه الانديه اليها والثاني طرح عدد من
الانديه الرياضيه لتخصيص للتخصيص بدءا من
الربع الاخير من العام الجاريث 2023
المشروع يهدف الى جعل الدوري السعودي ضمن
قائمه افضل عرش دوريات عالميه وزياده
ارادته الى مليار و800 مليون ريال سنويا
فضلا عن رفع قيمه السوقيه للدوري السعودي
للمحترفين من ثلاثه مليارات الى اكثر من
ثمانيه مليارات ريال
[موسيقى]
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات